eindeutiges ergebnis in den usa
präsidentschaftskandidat beiden gewinnt
auch georgia und baut seine mehrheit aus
österreich macht dicht die regierung
verschärft wegen hoher corona zahlen die
ausgangs beschränkungen und schließt
alle schulen fußball in schwierigen
zeiten des nations league spiel gegen
die ukraine kann trotz mehrerer corona
fälle stattfinden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am samstag mit
norbert könig für den sport schon
genommen und wir beginnen wieder mal mit
der präsidentschaftswahl in den usa die
ja immer noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen
ist obwohl sich der sieg von joe biden
immer stärker zementiert in georgia wird
derzeit aufgrund des knappen ergebnisses
noch mal alles von hand nachgezählt bis
mitte nächster woche soll das dann aber
auch erledigt sein
selbst im unwahrscheinlichen fall dass
georgia noch von blau auf roth wechselt
also doch an donald trump hat demokrat
joe biden seinen vorsprung bei den
wahlleute stimmen nahezu sicher 306 sind
ist derzeit und auch ohne den südstaat
wären es mehr als die benötigten 270
amtsinhaber trump kommt auf 232 und
scheint sich medienberichten zufolge
langsam damit abzufinden dass auch
gerichte das kaum noch ändern werden
ines trams sie hatten darauf gehofft
dass er sich blicken lässt und
tatsächlich auf dem weg zum golfplatz
dreht präsident trump eine runde durch
die demonstration aus allen teilen des
landes sind sie nach washington gekommen
anhänger kramp auch die von ganz rechts
ihre botschaft wahlbetrug dieses
wahlergebnis stimmt nicht wir stehen an
seiner seite
wir müssen unseren präsidenten
unterstützen bis zur endgültigen zählung
ist er noch immer der präsident
wir wollen zeigen trump ist der
rechtmäßige gewinner dieser wahl
doch am abend wird herausforderer joe
biden auch im umkämpften georgia zum
sieger ausgerufen
damit liegt er uneinholbar vorn die
manuelle nachzählung wird daran nichts
ändern
trump spricht nach wie vor von
wahlbetrug auch wenn gerichte fast all
seine klage abgeschmettert haben bei
einem statement zum corona impfstoff
räumt er erstmals ansatzweise seine
niederlage ein in einem versprecher
diese regierung wird keinen lockdown
machen hoffentlich wird die die
wer weiß was passiert welche regierung
es sein wird das wird sich zeigen aber
ich kann ihnen versichern diese
regierung wird keinen lockdown machen
unklar wann und ob überhaupt von ihm je
ein offizielles eingeständnis einer
niederlage kommt freunde trumps
beruhigen mir gesagt er wird das
richtige tun
ich habe nicht den eindruck dass er den
umsturz der gewählten regierung plant
joe biden entspannt heute auf dem
fahrrad er plant die übergangsphase zu
seiner regierung auch wenn drum ihm
dabei bislang viele hürden in den weg
legt ja auch demonstrationen werden am
wahlergebnis nichts mehr ändern können
fragen wir unseren washington
korrespondenten elmar theveßen
stimmt der eindruck dass präsident trump
gerade seine rhetorik ändert und den
wahlsieg nicht mehr für sich reklamiert
es gibt einige anzeichen dafür hat
beispielsweise ein anwalts team aus
arizona abgezogen aber er hat eben auch
von gerichten in arizona in pennsylvania
und michigan gesagt bekommen dass da
keine belege sind für wahlbetrug
jetzt hat er seinen persönlichen anwalt
wo die giuliani beauftragt weil er keine
star kanzleien hier in den usa mehr
findet zurzeit dies trotzdem weiter öl
ins feuer will offenbar eine legende am
leben halten auch wenn er das amt
verlassen dürfte im januar
er hat hier sich vorhin gezeigt vor den
demonstranten er hat getwittert diese
wahl ist gestohlen
diese legende bilder erhalten das ist
gefährlich wir haben hier hinter uns
etwa 10.000 demonstranten darunter
mehrere hundert milizionäre die vorhin
hier an uns vorbei marschiert sind
es sind also nicht nur ich sag mal
normale enttäuschte wähler
rampl in den nächsten wochen weitere
kundgebungen wohl abhalten in diesem
stil
er will die macht behalten über die
republikanische partei und das schafft
natürlich eine ich sag mal hoch
explosive situation im land weil
befürworter von trump und seine gegner
aufeinander prallen können
die einordnung von elmar theveßen
washington vielen dank dafür immer die
korona pandemie hat europa weiter fest
im griff
in österreich hat am nachmittag
bundeskanzler kurz noch schärfere
maßnahmen verkündet denn trotz des
bereits verhängten teil shutdowns steigt
die zahl der neuinfektionen weiter
massiv an
innerhalb von sieben tagen haben sich in
österreich pro 100000 einwohner 543 mit
dem corona virus angesteckt im vergleich
dazu sind es in deutschland mit einer
incidents von 141 deutlich weniger
britta hilpert berichtet aus wien
sie sind am limit in österreich intensiv
medizin immer noch steigt die zahl der
neuinfektionen sie ist weltweit eine der
höchsten und es steigt damit auch die
zahl der intensivpatienten mitmacht
müssen nun neue infektionen eingedämmt
werden mahnen ärzte wir werden beginnen
müssen die nächsten tage wenn das so
weiter geht zu entscheiden in welchem
umfang wir welche patienten mit intensiv
medizin behandeln können
die regierung zieht die notbremse
verschärfter lockt ab dienstag
meine eindringliche bitte für die
nächsten wochen ist treffen sie
niemanden jeder sozialer kontakt ist
einer zu viel
und so ist das heute der letzte shopping
samstag bis mindestens siebter dezember
nicht lebensnotwendige handel muss ab
dienstag schließen nur noch mit einer
person außerhalb des eigenen haushalts
darf man sich dann treffen schon seit
zehn tagen ist die gastronomie
geschlossen bald gelten ausgangs
beschränkungen den ganzen tag nur für
lebensnotwendiges für die arbeit und
kurz zur erholung dürfen österreich
heraus
gerade das einzige was man halt machen
kann dezember vor wochen für zwei drei
wochen radikal dafür ist der doktor nun
allumfassend ab mittwoch gibt es für
alle schüler nur noch fernunterricht
kinder notbetreuung gibt es bei
dringende bedarf mit den drastischen
maßnahmen will die regierung das
weihnachtsgeschäft und die
familienfeiern retten damit das aufgeht
müssen nun alle mitziehen
schauen wir auf die korona zahlen in
deutschland da ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen zwar leicht gesunken
bleibt aber weiter auf hohem niveau
das robert koch institut meldet 22 1461
neue fälle innerhalb eines tages die
entwicklung der absoluten zahlen zeigt
die neuansteckungen gehen insgesamt
leicht zurück am samstag vergangener
woche waren es noch 23 1399
seit zwei wochen gelten bundesweit
wieder strenger kontakt beschränkungen
manche landkreise in denen die zahlen
besonders hoch waren oder sind gehen
sogar noch darüber hinaus
das niedersächsische delmenhorst hatte
bereits mitte oktober mehr als 200
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
innerhalb einer woche und schickte zum
beispiel die schulen wieder in den
wechsel betrieb inzwischen sehen die
zahlen dort wieder besser aus anders im
landkreis hildburghausen in thüringen
dort ist der 7 tagesschnitt auf 274
gestiegen trotz strikter war regeln
florian coaching düster blickt landrat
thomas müller auf die neuesten corona
zahlen schon wieder sind sie gestiegen
für ihn steht fest auch kitas und
schulen sind infektions treiber
vorübergehend will er alle schließen
lassen
dafür hatte einen antrag ans
thüringische gesundheitsministerium
gestellt doch von dort eine absage hier
steht zum beispiel die komplette
schließung der schulen kindergärten und
kindertagesstätten ist unverhältnismäßig
wenn sie sehen unsere insolvenzzahlen
die steigerungen die wir haben dann ist
dieser satz schon
so bleiben ihnen weiter nur einzelfall
entscheidungen wie bei dieser schule die
ab montag geschlossen bleibt als
infektionsherde gelten in hildburghausen
zwei private feiern vor drei wochen
warum die zahlen nun hier immer noch
steigen ist unklar
offenbar scheint der ernst der lage
nicht überall angekommen zu sein
freilich hält sich hier dann musst du
aber wenn du eben pop geworden du stehst
du um der hitze die freilich ohne
ausgehöhlt und schließt freilich nord
gegen übung im frühjahr war das hygiene
konzept auf jeden fall viel besser als
jetzt
speziell in den einkaufsmärkten
baumärkten im niedersächsischen
delmenhorst ist man einen schritt weiter
als die infektionszahlen hier anfang
oktober in die höhe schossen wurde ein
teil shutdown verhängt drei wochen vor
dem rest der republik
seitdem sinken die zahlen auch dank
einer groß angelegten mehrsprachigen
aufklärungskampagne sagt der
bürgermeister wir haben das dadurch
erreicht dass wir die menschen erreicht
haben wir haben sehr viel in der
kommunikation noch mal getan sei es über
rundfunk sei es aber auch über die
zeitung noch mehr aufklären wollen sie
auch in hildburghausen auch mit
unterstützung der bundeswehr
und alle hoffen dass auch hier die
verhängten corona maßnahmen endlich
wirkung zeigen in mehreren städten in
deutschland gab es auch an diesem
samstag wieder demonstrationen der
sogenannten querdenker gegen die korona
maßnahmen in frankfurt am main gingen
mehrere hundert auf die straße viele von
ihnen ohne masken und sicherheitsabstand
gegendemonstrantinnen versuchten immer
wieder die strecke zu blockieren
die polizei setzte wasserwerfer ein die
abschlusskundgebung der querdenker wurde
aufgelöst wegen der verstöße gegen die
hygieneregeln seit beginn der pandemie
sammeln millionen hierzulande
erfahrungen mit dem home office
obwohl viele arbeitgeber und
arbeitgeberinnen skeptisch sind
arbeitsminister heil spd wollte
eigentlich einen rechtsanspruch auf home
office einräumen für 24 tage im jahr
das hat er nun aufgegeben denn cdu und
csu sagen nein
jetzt sollen beschäftigte mit dem chef
oder der chefin zu mindern
ein ernsthaftes gespräch über mobiles
arbeiten einfordern können schlägt teil
jetzt von nach afrika genauer gesagt
nach äthiopien dem land des friedens
nobelpreisträgers abu ahmed äthiopiens
regierungschef hat international für
aufmerksamkeit gesorgt weil er
demokratische reformen durchsetzte und
sein land mit dem benachbarten eritrea
befriedeten jetzt ist seine regierung in
einen neuen krieg vermittelt verwickelt
gegen die abtrünnige provinz tigray im
norden äthiopiens tim kröger fasst
zusammen
seit etwas mehr als zehn tagen wird
gekämpft im norden äthiopiens und schon
jetzt in tausende vor den
auseinandersetzungen in das nachbarland
sudan geflüchtet es gibt dort kein essen
kein wasser berichtet diese frau alle
sind weggerannt auf dem weg haben wir
mit äxten und messern ermordete menschen
gesehen
internationale beobachter warnen vor
einer humanitären katastrophe
informationen über die situation in der
umkämpften provinz tigray lassen sich
kaum überprüfen weil nur wenig nach
draußen dringt die kommunikationswege
sind abgeschnitten
diese videos sollen laut amnesty
international auf ein massaker hinweisen
mit möglicherweise hunderten toten wer
dafür verantwortlich ist konnte ist die
international bislang noch nicht
eindeutig klären
diese tötungen reflektieren die
anhaltenden ethnischen spaltungen im
landtag andré dabei galt der junge
regierungschef ahmed fielen bei
amtsantritt 2018 als hoffnungsträger
eröffnete äthiopien schloss frieden mit
erzfeind eritrea und bekam dafür 2009 10
den friedensnobelpreis die ethnischen
und politischen spannungen
vielvölkerstaat aber hat er nicht unter
kontrolle bekommen auch nicht den
konflikt mit den tigern die vor ihm das
land dominierten als abi an die macht
kam haben die tiger die macht verloren
und wurden so zu besonderen
gegenspielern des premierministers ein
konflikt der laut experten die gesamte
region destabilisieren könnte und nun zu
einem faszinierenden iv und den
ägyptische forscher heute der
öffentlichkeit präsentiert haben mehr
als 100 holz sarkophage aus fahrerischer
zeit wie bunte bemalung erstaunlich gut
erhalten genau wie die mumien darin
gefunden haben die archäologen sie knapp
25 kilometer südlich von kairo in
sakkara auf dem gelände der berühmten
stufenpyramide von dort berichtet uli
gack es ist ein besonderer moment weit
über 2000 jahre liebt die ruhe des edlen
ungestört ein hohepriester gut sein
sarkophag vor kurzem entdeckt in sakkara
die altägyptische toten stadt südlich
kairo und ein ausgräber der unworte
klingt es ist ein so wunderschönes
gesicht
ich weiß nicht wie ich mich ausdrücken
soll
die hülle ist perfekt erhalten so schöne
dekorieren überall
dutzende statuen zahlreiche masken mehr
als 100 sarkophage wurden zuletzt
entdeckt wer die menschen waren ihre
stellung ihre rolle in der gesellschaft
soll wohl noch erforscht werden
die arbeit hier ist noch nicht getan es
geht weiter vor ende des jahres oder
kurz danach werden wir weitere
entdeckungen viele grabbeigaben sind
außerordentlich gut erhalten
kaum zu glauben dass sie schon eine
ewigkeit unter der erde waren alles wird
gereinigt und konserviert die funde
sollen so bleiben wie sie entdeckt
wurden heißt es hier
bereits im oktober hatten ägyptische
archäologen hier etwa 60 ungeöffnete
sarkophage in einem unterirdischen grab
komplex entdeckt dass sein in sakkara
birgt noch viele geheimnisse der genaue
fundort der 100 mühlen ist geheim
toll vom sport lange stand das spiel der
dfb elf gegen die ukraine auf der kippe
aber jetzt steht fest heute abend gibt's
fußball im zdf ja aber das ist schön
dass freud sicherlich die fans und auch
die spieler und wahrscheinlich auch
bundestrainer joachim löw der dürfte
zufrieden sein dass es vor drei stunden
grünes licht für die partie in der
nations league gegeben hat trotz fünf
positiver corona tests im team der
ukraine boris büchler ist in leipzig wie
schwierig war denn dieser
entscheidungsprozess boris ja es war den
ganzen tag eine komplizierte geschichte
schon am vormittag am frühen morgen hat
das leipziger gesundheitsamt
festgestellt dass es keine
kontaktpersonen der ersten kategorie
gibt bei den ukrainern das heißt es gab
keinen engen kontakt zwischen den fünf
getesteten und weiteren spielern und
delegationsmitgliedern nur deswegen
musste die ukraine nicht in quarantäne
am nachmittag gab es dann weitere
testungen alle testungen dann negativ
16.30 dann die entscheidung es wird
gespielt ganz kurz wie ist das alles
beim dfb und den spielern angekommen
für die dfb funktionäre war es kein
sorgenfreier samstag denn das spiel
stand auf der kippe war kurz vor der
absage
joachim löw und seine mannschaft hat
sich ganz normal
er bereitet sportlich ist zu sagen bis
auf den gesperrten groß und den
verletzten kimmig werden sie in
bestbesetzung antreten heißt sie gehen
als favorit ins spiel gegen den leicht
dezimierten gegner boris büchler vielen
dank um 20.15 uhr sport extra aus
leipzig die zusammenfassung anderer
nations league spiele anschließend im
aktuellen sportstudio
maximilian levy hat bei den bahnrad
europameisterschaften in plowdiw zum
ersten mal den titel im sprint gewonnen
der cottbus aber auf eigene
verantwortung ins risikogebiet bulgarien
gereist nachdem der bund deutscher
radfahrer die meldung des kompletten
teams wegen corona bedenken
zurückgezogen hatte premiere auch für
einen kanadier im rosa rennwagen lance
stroll sichert sich zum ersten mal die
pole position bei einem formel 1 grand
prix als qualifikations schnellster in
istanbul
heute ist was los in istanbul zuerst ein
vierbeiner und schließlich einen
kanadier lance stroll gelingt die
überraschung des tages und fährt beim
regen qualifying vor max verstappen und
sergio perez auf die pole position
ob weltmeister lewis hamilton morgen
seinen siebten titel gewinnen kann ist
fraglich der brite startet von platz 6
sebastian vettel hadert mit den reifen
und wird zwölfter
lance stroll seit 23 jahren seit jacques
villeneuve der erste kanadier wieder auf
der pole position
[Applaus]
danke der sonntag bringt nur sehr
sonnenschein und milde temperaturen dann
von westen her regen mehr zum wetter
gleich von katja hornuf so viel von uns
danke für ihr interesse
das heute journal mit claus kleber in
der halbzeitpause um halb zehn und wir
sind morgen wieder für sie da punkt 7
einen schönen entspannten fußball abend
im zdf
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren der
tropensturm jota ist der dreißigste
tropische wirbelsturm über dem
nordatlantik in dieser saison und der
zieht weiter richtung nicaragua und
honduras aber auch für europa gibt es
zurzeit einen tropensturm der zieht ganz
ungewöhnlich nämlich ostwärts und peilt
jetzt madeira an für uns in mitteleuropa
ist täter nicht interessant sondern
roswitha roswitha bringt erst mal milde
temperaturen mit dann viel wind und
regen und danach etwas tiefere
temperaturen heute nacht fällt ein
bisschen regen an der nordsee sonst ist
es häufig nur locker bewölkt an der
donau bildet sich nebel
die temperaturen im alpenvorland sinken
auf null bis minus ein grad da droht
also bodenfrost und die straßen können
noch klappt sein
sonst bleibt es milder bei 12 bis 5 grad
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 9 grad an der donau und 19 grad
am oberrhein und der sonntag beginnt
erstmal sehr freundlich sonnenschein und
wolken wechseln sich ab und allenfalls
an der donau hält sich noch länger neben
der wind frischt schon auf er kommt aus
südlichen richtungen und am nachmittag
werden die wolken von westen dichter und
dann beginnt es auch zum teil kräftig zu
schützen und deutlich wechselhafter geht
es dann in die neue woche und ein
kleines bisschen kühler wird auch
schönes wochenende